what we're going to do is we're going to
snappy to you about this is a visual
process rather than the case there's
give you two stationary points in this
thing right we can find those stationary
present in calculus but we can there are
other tools at our disposal we can use
that we don't need to use okay so for
instance it's actually kind of important
that you've got like a reasonable scale
this usually it kind of doesn't matter
what the X or the Y scale are relative
to each other but because we're going to
try and make is visual and argument as
we can the more accurate your diagram is
the more you'll be helped to see for
example you can see I tried my best to
get y equals x and y equals 1 over X
I've tried my best to get them to
intersect somewhere that's basically
squares because what is that point I
don't know other corners that point
should be it should be 1 1 ok now I'm
going to use that as my example because
you'll see that what happens is when
you're adding and subtracting ordinates
someone that's very easy to add and
others are kind of more complicated ok
so for instance if I've got what I'm
doing is I'm adding these two graphs
together the two graphs that agreed and
together to make this composite graph
okay
I know that at that point 4x equals 1
right but my trigger events are both
equal to they ordinates upper is equal
to 1 that's why they get to set here
right so when I add one plus one well I
should get two right so therefore I'm
gonna go right to the point twice as
high as that and I'm gonna say okay babe
there you go I'm gonna put an X I tend
to indicate X's you know how use X's for
the root so don't put a family I'm
passing through there that's where I
should go
all right by it by analogy I mean what
I've got here is an odd function I've
got one function plus another one
function so when you put them together
you get just a great I'm adding right
where we used to thinking about
multiplying and dividing on you can see
if I put F of minus X into here what's
going to happen
I'm going to get minus x squared plus 1
all over minus X simplify a little bit
put that minus sign in front and then
you've got x squared plus 1 over X and
that's the opposite of what I started so
this the whole thing is an odd function
so if you add two odd functions you get
another one function so therefore by
analogy see how I had one on one here
and I hadn't beyond its it went up so
over here I've got negative one and
negative one if I add those all of it
I'll go down there should be negative
tubes that make sense so I've got
negative one as the x-coordinate and
then if that's negative one negative two
would be down there all right now what
else is happening here trying to make a
visual argument yeah so the next thing
I'm going to notice is and we're going
to formally say all this later on but
we're just trying to get a right picture
okay
the domain of this whole function like
composite function right the domain of
the composite function is going to be
the intersection or the overlap of the
domains of all the parts on adding
together does that make sense
think about it right for this thing to
exist all of the bits and pieces also
have to exist right so for a tipple we
already know that from on this site the
domain of y equals x is is all real X
right
but the domain of 1 over X is not the
same right the domain of 1 over X can be
X is less than zero and X is greater
than 0 right so being an 80 both pieces
to exist for this guy to exist right the
domain of this time will be awesome xs/s
is zero X is one easier so I'm going to
have an asymptote here just like I do
for whatever X ok in fact pretty much
what you'll find is that if you've got
an asymptotes up here you're very likely
going to have asymptotes know it's a
very very common feature
okay now let's get to this um this your
extremity behavior okay now what I have
a look at the heel I'm gonna try and
make again a visual argument right now
you can see Mike was X is going to carry
on and keep growing up with this
direction play what am i adding to it
okay here's one over X what I'm adding
as I get further and further this wave
is a smaller and smaller and smaller do
you see that right
why cause X just keeps on doing its
thing but when I add to it gets it gets
full it approaches zero doesn't it okay
so if what you're doing is like actually
get your ruler for a second okay get you
a liver second and measure out like we
already know that that's one possibility
okay a little bit further okay so for
instance you actually can do Mary
Foligno even if your graph is not
completely accurate if I go over to x
equals two then up here either to where
will my whatever X graph be think about
it it's it's at 1 over 2 right because
this graph is 1 over X thinking about 82
so this should be 1/2 my scale is not
100% as you can see okay but what I'm
gonna have is adding up a little bit
more right you see that distance and
that distance are smaller these two
distances that I just put onto the
ground should correspond to these two if
I'm gonna get my other column and we're
going to say this distance here is going
to manage this distance here and this
distance is going to match this distance
and what I'm adding each time I'll do
one more just I can just feel it I think
if I want to have an x equals three I'm
adding on a third that little chunk
right this little tiny distance in there
right
well that distance will correspond to a
little distance up here right now you
can see what's happening you can see if
there's asymptotic behavior up here
precisely because this asymptotic
behavior over here does that make sense
so you're adding something that's
getting increasingly close on to this
guy up here right
so in fact y equals x is that asymptote
can you see look at my points as I'm
going I'm getting closer and closer to
close all right I have to get closer and
closer closer
because that's what this guy's okay all
right now the same way like I can I
could join these up in a second I'm
going to it emit it in the same way I
can see to the left here well how would
you characterize what's happening here
so you know how we said oh look at look
at these see how they're approaching
zero right well why was X is also
approaching zero as I move closer to the
origin do you see that look at those
distances in there closer to zero or
close to zero zero questions etc so when
I add these little distances up here
they're also going to get smaller and
smaller and smaller right so in fact I'm
gonna get something like this you see
how they're going to shrink in exactly
the same way that these guys are gonna
shrink okay so now I've got this kind of
shape happening up here great in fact I
am I'm not going to draw it because it
starts to get confusing but if I wanted
to say it I have the same kind of SM 24
haveon approaching x equals 0 just like
I haven't approaching everything I'm
just approaching a different asymptote y
equals 1 over X is my asymptotes I'll
never get there why would I ever touch
like was one of Rex
good the only point where an Emma touch
is if what I'm adding is zero that means
I'll actually be on that graph but I
never get there right I can't because x
equals 0 is not invite their name that
make sense so now I've got these points
up here that's enough of a shame there's
nothing else interesting here are the
Wiggles all those kinds of things that
would change the behavior of my graph so
I'm going to join the dots okay
something like this
okay so do you see how my made that
shape okay I've got a stationary point
then I can I don't have to have the
stationary point somewhere because I
know up here I've got a client right
it's all gonna have a decrease he graded
here and over here I'm also a club so
I'm gonna have an increase in review so
if I've got a decrease to increase it
that's kind of the definition of a
turning point isn't it right so
therefore it's why I had one somewhere
in here and that's not enough to know
exactly where it is but I don't need to
know exactly where it is to do my
initiative ordinance that's what these
other words are about it exactly the
same way I'm gonna make my diamond over
here I don't need to rehearse it it's an
odd function right so I'm gonna get the
same kind of behavior on this side
that's it that's the graph that's how I
would pro approach X plus 1 over X by
look at these component graphs and then
adding them together